over Jonathan Isaac to make sure that  the man's limit them to one and done  Luca driving stumbling fights once and  once and got it to go and change it is  off to a perfect start three for three  just as steady as they come you know  Luke is going to give it up between the  legs and Jalen comfortably knocks it  down  that's good touch always looking for  open he's able to finish one of these  dogs excellent pass to the Lando's  defense was whipping out you can with  the driving with a Jonathan Simmons Jake  wanted three-pointer him this time one  situation steep Clifford has seen enough  signed the people around the perimeter  of the dribble penetration over the  Brunson 2 for 3 from the floor he's now  missed seven straight shots maybe he  could break the drought  [Applause]  finish by the military Jordan  I mean that's a good score down love  missin chippies with horns inside his  boots image